oh my god his status hey whoa damn Danis
I didn't realize you were so thick
damn boy Jesus how's it going bros my
name is ping and promise I love that
sound
alright yes I'm still playing this game
roughly I've added mods to the game
which makes it even crazier than it used
to be and it's honestly the best ever so
let's frickin jump into it it's a fresh
day for some fresh knees ah
let's pick the hardest difficulty and
let's freakin do this I'm ready like
I've never been ready before oh my god
please please I don't want to hit a
woman
wait ah what's wrong with you
as for your hippie things huh Oh Derek
ah come here tell me your knees up [ __ ]
yeah
[Music]
alright let's try that again oh my god
oh my god his famous fan
whoa damn Danice I didn't realize you
were so thick oh my god oh these are
some precious knees bye
oh yeah that tie we Freck didn't do it
in Sweden bro all right let's get some
real action
[Music]
oh hi sorry oh oh sorry
you're nice on line 9 Swedish jump
attack ah ah stay down stay down stay
down
are you still alive do you regret what
you did but too late bye ha ha ha
who wants them Jesus Christ so
ridiculous huh
I got damn it I didn't do anything
excuse me one second ma'am
don't come near me don't come near me
I'll never hit a woman please please Vox
is lit all right you did it that was you
huh get your nice that is not as cool as
I wanted it to be are you still alive oh
my god it's still alive excuse me we
don't have to fight anymore oh look a
sphere now I'd like to put it where it
belongs
not one nice I got two nice I was born
in the knees i was bled by the meatballs
speaking lead jitsu nothing to see here
you two nothing to see here
all right let's change man wow what an
adventure but there's more places to go
and more knees to be found
let's go to the market and acquire it
nice legally
[Music]
what's on the menu Oh what's crazy
endless okay let's do that oh my god
it's so tiny that is so cute it just
died right away oh sorry excuse me gonna
have that back please
which you're shooting arrows at me
really please please don't hurt me don't
hurt you will never walk you hit a
whamming how cute you
oopsie MBC hey what are you gonna do huh
what are you gonna do uh terrible sneak
attack sneak attack
oh it's got me pants
yeah where did she go oh there she is
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my god yeah
and me Nate ah yeah ah she knows how to
block
[Music]
shame on you shame on ya
give me back my new dagger Oh what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do
useless the fanny
[Music]
ah ah you're crazy
you could hurt me huh
just wait until I get you just with you
until I get those knees I was wrong with
you are you kidding me damn it
[Music]
Hey ah-ah-ah what have I done
please I'm having a moment I'm having a
real bad day please please I beg you
I have nothing to live for I got nothing
and no one that's what you thought [ __ ]
I don't care if one watch says I'll hit
any child
I mean person
please don't hurt me please don't oh my
god you fell for that
you're gonna pay you're gonna pay your
knees are useless have a bucket ningún
back it up
neat
[Music]
oops I fight you all with my bucket
anyone else one bucket look what tell me
child
where is your knees I don't know why
they I know you have them where are they
hidden to me I'm gonna ask you one last
time
where are your knees okay I think it's a
mess up smash like you'll need some wine
[Music]
oh he's got knee pants give me back my
new dagger just with you until I get
those knees your knees are useless
where are your knees don't talk to me
about needs my Chinese it might oh I
don't think so doctor fell cuz I are you
gonna keep copy striking my videos dr.
Phil huh
Shh goddamnit you want pyramids we got
oh oh you're into castles huh we got you
covered baby you want some pets easy
we got it all this game is still
relevant goddammit